the official announcement from the
national football league came thursday
the competition committee unanimously
recommended the rule approved in march
for instant replay of pass interference
remain in effect for the 2019 season
only that tells me that they're going to
ditch this replay review of past
interference after the 100th season in
the nfl and it also tells me they got
more to do to feel good about the new
procedures for replay review of pass
interference for the nfl's 100 season
look shireen the nfl wants nothing to
undermine this season-long celebration
this past interference replay
rule has the potential to do it because
we're either going to be talking every
monday and every tuesday and every
friday after games have been played
about too many replay reviews too many
stoppages the last two minutes of the
game taking way too long or we're going
to be talking about situations where we
think there was pass interference that
wasn't called on the field and there
should have been a replay review to
overturn it the sweet spot on this one i
think is very narrow and it's going to
be so hard for 17 different replay
officials to be on the same page this is
a potential nightmare for the nfl and i
don't think they appreciate how big of a
deal this could be and my hope is
there's somebody out there who's making
about 50 million a year to run the nfl
who cares about this as much as we do
and is committed to doing something to
fix it before the season begins
yeah and i don't know really what the
fix is at this point the coaches have
gotten their way and this is how it's
going to stand as you said for this year
and then they'll review it again and
possibly do something different or ditch
it and do nothing but the reason they've
never done a rule like this for replay
expanded replays because it is so
subjective and every person has a
different definition of exactly what
interference is i we all know what
happened at the nfc into the nfc
championship game was interference we
can all agree on that one but there's
going to be so many of these plays that
we disagree on and 99 people out of 100
in a bar are not going to agree on it
but is that one replay official going to
agree that it needs to be reviewed and
17 of them are going to have probably
differing opinions on whether that
should happen or not and it's all going
to be dependent on who that replay
official is as to whether that play gets
reviewed in real time not slowed down
but in real time and so i think that's
the difficulty of this thing and they
face an impossible thing here these
replay officials and i i feel for them
because they're going to be under the
spotlight more than they've ever been in
a really really long time
and shireen that's what got me concerned
about this earlier in the week when mike
girardi of nfl media tweeted that al
riverron was explaining it in nfl media
summit that the chargers chief's late
game pass interference call against
kansas city from week 15 on that
thursday night thriller it was past
interference called against kendall
fuller when mike williams is trying to
catch the pass in the end zone riveron
said that would have been reviewed and
it would have been determined that mike
williams also committed offensive pass
interference the
end result would have been offsetting
fouls and the chargers would have had
the ball back on the 10-yard line third
and goal
um when i saw that i thought
maybe we're not going to be activating
replay review only when it's truly
obvious like it was in the ram saints
game see i think they need just that
safety net break glass and event of
emergency type of a thing i don't want
all these rulings of past interference
to be subject to replay review because
it is so subjective and it is something
that you can look at it 10 different
ways before you realize where the
problem is i only want replay review or
whatever they use sky judge whatever to
be involved when the outcome on the
field is clearly and obviously wrong
that's the standard clear and obvious
for past interference it's got to be
clear and obvious along the lines of
what we saw in the rams saints game not
that week 15 mike williams maybe looked
like he was pushing a little bit that if
if that's subject to replay review that
feeds right into the concerns that i
have and that makes me think because al
riveron's already flagged that as
something that would be changed under
this new rule that this is going to be a
mess
yeah you're exactly right it's it's
those type of plays i think that we're
concerned about and it's going to slow
the game down which is why the nfl and
the competition committee wanted to go
back to let's have the coaches throw the
challenge flags even in the final two
minutes of each half and the coaches
said absolutely not because they don't
want to have to save their challenges
save their timeouts to be assured that
they have that when they need the
opportunity to challenge a pass
interference play so the coaches again
got their way in this thing by pushing
and pushing and pushing and this is not
at all what the nfl or the competition
committee wanted in the beginning or in
the end this isn't what they wanted
but but shireen the coaches are right
why should they have to budget a red
challenge flag for the last two minutes
of the game right in the event that
there's a major blunder like we saw in
the ram saints game i mean the nfl
should come up with a solution that
addresses the problem that happened in
january and only that problem that's
what dean blandino told deadspin earlier
this week dean blandino the former vp of
officiating if you create a rule for one
play even as obvious as that play was
you can get bad rules that way and
nobody wants that everybody wants to fix
that we want to fix what happened in the
rams saints game but we don't want it to
go farther than that right now this is
going to go farther than that and it's
going to be a problem for the nfl and
i'm just hoping the people out there who
are responsible for fixing the problem
realize it and do something about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports